bonjour et bienvenue au parlement
européen à bruxelles pour ce nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo
dans cette émission nous parlerons des
médicaments contrefaits en europe
aujourd'hui plus d'un médicament sur dix
est un faux mais d'abord l'actualité est
toute l'europe qui montre du doigt
israël
nous regrettons les pertes humaines ue
nous condamnons le recours à la violence
et nous demandons une enquête impartiale
immédiat et complet
paris berlin londres madrid l'assaut des
forces militaires israéliennes contre
une flottille d'aidé humanitaire à
destination de gaza a pour une fois fait
l'unanimité en europe outre la demande
d'une enquête complète pour établir les
responsabilités c'est aujourd'hui la
question du blocus israélien sur la
bande de gaza qui se posent
il est important d'ouvrir les points de
passage pour le transit de l'aide
humanitaire et pour assurer ainsi de
meilleures conditions de vie à la
population
de son côté l'egypte à lever les
restrictions au point de passage de
rafah afin de permettre à l'aide
humanitaire d'être acheminée vers gaza
il y a quelques jours une délégation de
parlementaires européens en visite dans
les territoires palestiniens s'est vu
interdire l'accès à la bande de gaza par
le gouvernement israélien
finalement entrés par l'egypte les
parlementaires vont également demander
la levée du blocus cas ici des énormes
besoins humanitaires qui ne sont pas
satisfaits pour des raisons politiques
donc jamais on voit aussi clairement
clairement la situation et monétaire la
situation politique est lié
si israël ne lève pas les plats les
blocages des frontières de gaza
nous pouvons pas être vraiment efficace
avec notre aide humanitaire
une aide humanitaire freiné par ce
blocus qui dure depuis trois ans suite à
l'arrivée au pouvoir en juin 2007 du
hamas il y à 18 mois la guerre
dévastatrice menée par les israéliens à
gaza a surtout renforcé le joug du parti
islamiste sur cette petite bande de
terre
une situation qui n'arrange en rien le
processus de paix on a l'impression que
les choses s'aggravent et qu' il ya une
difficulté croissante des deux parties
en cause à à remettre sur les rails le
processus de paix face aux etats unis
seul intermédiaire dans les tentatives
de résolution au proche orient l'europe
est en retrait pourtant elle paye c'est
le premier contributeur dans les
territoires palestiniens
et malgré la création d'un service
diplomatique par le traité de lisbonne
les vingt-sept ne se sont pas encore
saisi du dossier
voilà c'est un sujet signé n'aura
hammadi et retour à bruxelles au
parlement européen nous sommes avec
nicole kiil nielsen bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputée française des verts vous
suivez de près la situation au
proche-orient et vous étiez justement
dans la délégation de députés qu'on a
vue qui s'est rendu
dans les territoires palestiniens alors
expliquez nous en quelques mots comment
ça s'est passé parce qu'on a eu beaucoup
d'informations contradictoires on a
parlé en donner que des députés
européens se trouvaient sur le bateau ce
qui n'était pas le cas en quelques mots
est ce que vous avez pu vous rendre à
gaza oui nous étions à gaza une partie
de la délégation s'est effectivement
rendu à gaza mais il faut savoir quand
même que les autorités israéliennes nous
ont interdit l'accès à gaza par les
frontières israéliennes par le passage
d'erez
nous avons donc décidé un groupe de neuf
personnes avec eva joly de nous rendre
en au caire par avion et ensuite nous
avons pris un autobus pour nous rendre à
la raf a bien sûr nous avions l'accord
des autorités égyptiennes et nous sommes
entrés à gaza
et est-ce que vous qui avez donc été sur
place bon c'est quelque chose et les
senti que les choses s'aggravent est
tout à fait la situation de la
population au civil est vraiment
déplorable c'est à dire que vous qu'on
voit bien que le strict minimum est là
pour survivre mais les gazaouis n'ont
pas le droit à la vie les tunnels que
nous avons pu voir leur permettre de
recevoir un certain nombre de biens de
maths de choses à eux qui sont
nécessaires à la vie mais il manque
énormément de choses là elle 80% de la
population de gaza vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté 80% vit de l'aide humanitaire
et les la plupart des gazaouis sont au
chômage puisqu'ils ne peuvent pas
évidemment travaillé on a pu voir grâce
à aux représentants de l'unrwa qui nous
a expliqué et montré des chalonnais l'
agence de l'onu
des chantiers qui sont tous suspendus de
construction de logements alors que les
populations vivent dans des bidonvilles
mais est ce que finalement c'est cette
économie des tunnels dont on vous
parlait n'aimait pas contre-productif
financer les conséquences de ce blocus
aussi puisque ces tunnels sont quand
même largement contrôlé par le par le
ramasse qui imposent des taxes
importantes
c'est contre-productif raison ce sont ou
le hamas ou d'autres factions islamistes
qui en fait gère les tunnels et récupère
beaucoup d'argent grâce à ça donc c'est
vraiment politiquement je ne comprends
pas pourquoi israël maintient le blocus
qui en fait permet aux extrémistes de
renforcer
leur pouvoir dans cette région cela
punit la population c'est une véritable
punition collective et ça n'a aucun
intérêt qui aujourd'hui l'europe qu'elle
quels moyens l'europe at-elle d'obtenir
la levée de ce blocus en ce que l'europe
a vraiment des moyens l'europe est le
premier partenaire commercial d'israël
tout savoir qu israël exporte 80% de ses
productions en europe donc l'europe peut
suspendre et c'est ce que nous demandons
la suspension de l'accord entre l'union
européenne et israël
et ça ça me paraît indispensable aux
sanctions c'est une forme de pression
pour obtenir de la part d'israël la fin
du blocus de gaza est également suite au
drame qui vient de se produire
évidemment nous demandons qu'une enquête
internationale et indépendante soit est
réalisé et que nous attendons évidemment
les résultats
alors justement qui doit la mener cette
enquête est ce que c'est l'union
européenne qu'elle serait plus légitime
pour la meilleure l'onu l'a fait
légitime pour le faire et que vraiment
il faut comprendre que l'union
européenne est vraiment la mieux placée
je dirais même avec les états unis bien
sûr mais l'union européenne est vraiment
le partenaire le plus important d'israël
est également l'union européenne finance
énormément les territoires palestiniens
et à gaza l'aide humanitaire vient d'
union européenne donc je pense que la
légitimité d'europe
elle est vraiment réel alors comment
expliquez vous qu'on a du mal à entendre
sa voix qu'elle qu'elle n'arrive pas à
jouer son rôle dans cette région
pourtant elle a peut-être vocation à le
faire avec ce fort de ses 60 ans que peu
de temps sur son continent
nous venons d'entendre madame ashton
dont j'espère qu effectivement c'est
nouveau au niveau du roc bon nous avons
maintenant une autre
commissaire aux relations
internationales donc j'espère que madame
ashton a comprises j'ai l'impression
qu'elle a compris puisqu'elle parle de
la fin du blocus donc elle ne s'est pas
contenté de parler de la question de l'
enquête qui est nécessaire bien sûr
suite à l'agression contre les bateaux
de la paix mais elle parle également de
la fin du blocus de gaza donc je pense
qu'il ya là une évolution intéressante
et je souhaite qu'effectivement nous
allions dans ce sens dit que c'est pour
le ces pour l'europe une occasion nous
dresse vraiment à je le crois mais je le
crois compter sur l'a2 on avait déjà il
ajouté il ya un an et demi lors de
l'agression fin 2008 début 2009 contre
la bande de gaza mais à ce moment là
nous n'avions pas madame ashton
je pense que maintenant nous allons
pouvoir agir et j'espère effectivement
malheureusement à cause d'un drame les
choses vont pouvoir avancer on ne peut
pas laisser israël continuer de cette
manière à fonctionner en toute impunité
là on redoute quand même une escalade de
la violence au vu de ce qui s'est passé
est ce que vous pensez que par exemple
envoyer une force européenne sur place
ça pourrait être une solution afin de
force d'interposition ça serait une des
solutions non je pense qu'effectivement
ce serait une des solutions parce que on
ne peut pas laisser face à face les
israéliens et les palestiniens
c'est pas possible ni même laissé les
partenaires les voisins je veux dire ça
ne peut pas se résoudre
et d'ailleurs la responsabilité on le
sait historique mais concerne également
l'europe la création de l'état d'israël
donc je crois que c'est important que
l'europe joue un rôle dans cette région
et s'interpose entre les différents
enfin entre israël et la palestine et
qu'on arrive enfin qu'on aboutisse à la
création d'un état palestinien viable
dans les frontières de 67
c'est le rêve a annoncé la position
officielle tout simplement de l'union
européenne avec jérusalem est comme
capitale
alors que là il n'y a pas de changement
on n'a pas changé de position
l'union européenne avaient émis sur
place une union pour la méditerranée
c'était l'un des projets phares de la
présidence française devait être aussi
une instance qui permettait aux
israéliens ou aux palestiniens de
dialoguer finalement ou est-elle si ça
n'avance pas et c'est vrai que le noeud
de cette union pour la méditerranée qui
concerne beaucoup de pays c'est la
question palestinienne donc il faut
effectivement avancer sur cette question
là pour ensuite pouvoir travailler dans
cette région de manière plus globale
c'est vraiment le noeud du problème et
vous ne traitez pas une escalade pour
les pour les jours qui viennent les
dernières déclarations notamment venues
d'iran et c'est clair les extrémistes
sont ravis et c'est là où la politique
d'israël est ambigu ont selon sa
terrasse justement sur une réelle
volonté de la part du gouvernement
actuel serait bien de trouver une
solution pacifique c'est pas évident
qu'on parle parce que ce type
d'événements tragiques fasse le jeu des
extrémismes les extrémistes des deux
côtés parce que le gouvernement
israélien actuel est un gouvernement
vraiment d'extrême droite il faut dire
les choses comme elles sont le
gouvernement est un gouvernement
d'extrême droite et qui ne joue pas non
plus la modération et qui ne recherche
pas une solution en même temps on
comprend que ce soit pas facile de
dialoguer avec le ramasse ses il faut
rappeler aussi les raisons de
l'instauration de ce blocus on va
écouter actuellement il ya à gaza plus
de 50% de la population qui a moins de
18 ans qu'on ne nous dise pas que ces
gens-là ont mal voté il ya trois ans la
plupart du de la population est très
jeune elle a même pas voter même si on
admettait le principe de la punition
pour avoir mal voté lors d'élections qui
se sont déroulées de manière tout à fait
démocratique à l'époque j'ai participé à
une commission internationale
d'observation de ces élections
tout le monde à zahlé non j'étais élu
dans ma région élu local et nous avons
observé les élections municipales il
nous concerne mais je sais que ça s'est
passé de la même manière
les élections législatives tout le monde
a validé le processus électoral alors
effectivement le résultat ne nous a pas
satisfaits mais bon alors nicole kiil
nielsen vous restez avec nous je vous
propose de voir les autres temps forts
de l'actualité européenne
en bref et en images l'euro n'en finit
plus de tomber en un mois la monnaie
unique a perdu 7 5% face au dollar
jour après jour les mauvaises nouvelles
creuse les perspectives de reprise
économique et les marchés s'affolent
l'inquiétude sur les dettes souveraines
des pays européens et la solvabilité des
états les dégradations successives des
notes de la grèce de l'espagne ou du
portugal
le taux de chômage au plus haut dans la
zone euro et les perspectives de
croissance faible autant d'éléments qui
inquiète les marchés et les
atermoiements des dirigeants de
l'eurogroupe dans la mise en place de
politique économique concertée n'arrange
pas la situation des atermoiements que
jean claude trichet voudrait voir
disparaître au profit d'une véritable
gouvernance économique
le président de la banque centrale
européenne s'est dit favorable à la mise
en oeuvre d'une fédération budgétaire
afin de surveiller les usages des
finances publiques de chaque état une
position qui rejoint celle de la
commission européenne procès manuel
barroso le président de la commission
souhaite obtenir un droit de regard sur
les budgets des pays membres de l'union
une position qui fait grincer des dents
dans certaines capitales notamment à
paris pourtant favorable à une meilleure
gouvernance économique dans la zone euro
barry qui résiste à bruxelles et s'arc
boute sur le statut public de la sncf
pour la commission ce statut garantit un
financement illimité de l'entreprise ce
qui constituerait une entorse au droit
de la concurrence
de son côté le gouvernement garantit que
la sncf restera un établissement public
un message à la commission mais surtout
au syndicat des transports des syndicats
qui ont d'ores et déjà rejeté violemment
l'idée d'une telle réforme
transformer la sncf en société anonyme
un dossier explosif que le gouvernement
se refuse d'ouvrir à l'heure de la
réforme des retraites
voilà pour ce tour d'europe alors un
autre dossier revient à la une celui de
la taxe carbone européenne la commission
elle n'a fait une proposition 20 euros
par tonne c'est le montant prévu pour
l'instant c'est à l'état de projet mais
est-ce que vous en tant que député des
verts vous trouvez que c'est une bonne
chose que c'est vous savez nous sommes
favorables le effectivement à la taxe
carbone c'est un c'est déjà pas mal moi
c'est peut-être pas suffisant mais
j'espère que nous allons adopter une
mesure de ce type effectivement nous
sommes tout à fait favorables à la taxe
carbone sur l'idée de la taxe carbone
dont on distingue aussi la taxe carbone
interne et la taxe aux frontières que
proposait nicolaï alors ça me paraît
quand même un peu choquant de parler d'
imposer aux autres ce qu'on n'arrive pas
à s'imposer à soi-même quoi je crois
qu'il faut commencer au niveau de
l'europe a montré que nous sommes nous
courageux et nous prenons des mesures et
après on demandera aux autres
effectivement s'inspirer de nos
démarches
merci beaucoup nicole kiil nielsen est
ce que vous vous acheter des médicaments
sur internet
non mais alors justement c'était pas si
mal parce que on a découvert qu'il ya
beaucoup de contrefaçons de médicaments
en europe c'est le dossier dont nous
parle france à vos années et oui la
contrefaçon des médicaments n'épargne
plus l'europe chaque année des millions
de faux cachets ou de fausses gélules
potentiellement dangereux débarque sur
notre continent
nous avons été enquêtés aux douanes de
francfort en allemagne
regardez ce reportage il est signé
florence maurice et fabrice qu'une haie
aéroport de francfort capitale
économique de l'allemagne
la troisième plate forme d'europe pour
le transport de courrier comme tous les
matins c'est l'effervescence au service
des douanes
c'est marcus qui dirige les opérations
l'an dernier rien qu'ici ses équipes ont
intercepté plus de 3 millions de faux
médicaments
écoutez là ça ça pourrait être des
médicaments et quels sont vos critères
pour repérer de faux médicaments
la provenance d'abord on regarde d'où
vient le paquet c'est sûr et puis là
aucune indication sur le contenu du plie
pas de nom de marque
c'est un indice important et puis quand
je le touche
on se dit qu'il ya de fortes chances que
ce soit des médicaments c'est internet
qui a fait exploser le trafic
ces deux dernières années ce trafic a
triplé en europe
il a même détrôné la cigarette au
palmarès de la contrefaçon
les stimulants sexuels voilà c'est ce
qu'on trouve le plus souvent cela
représente environ 80% des médicaments
intercepté vraiment notre plus gros
problème des produits qui viennent le
plus souvent en d'inde de chine ou des
états unis midi seulement et déjà une
dizaine de colis sous scellés une
matinée ordinaire aux douanes de
francfort
à quelques kilomètres au nord voici le
service d'investigation des douanes pour
la région c'est ici que l'on tente de
comprendre l'organisation de ces
nouvelles filières comprendre pourquoi
de telles quantités de faux médicaments
arrivent sur les marchés allemand et
européen
il faut bien se rendre compte que ce
trafic est extrêmement rentable
avec ça les vendeurs se font plus de
marges encore qu'avec le trafic de
cigarettes contrefaites de drogues ou
même la vente d'armes par exemple là
pour selon la fabrication coûte à peu
près 1000 euros et à la vente les
trafiquants vont toucher plus de 80000
euros
et le pire c'est que pour les coupables
les amendes sont plus faibles que pour
le trafic de cigarettes ou de droit y
est l'allemagne n'est pas le seul pays
touché par ce phénomène en europe
mais ici depuis 2004 les pharmacies
traditionnels ont le droit de proposer
leurs médicaments sur internet une
brèche pour les trafiquants qui en
profite pour créer de fausses pharmacies
en ligne au service d'investigation des
douanes on a recruté une équipe
d'enquêteurs chargés de traquer ces
sites illégaux tout ça là ce sont les
dossiers des fournisseurs internet sur
lesquels nous enquêtons en ce moment un
exemple classique d'un site illégal fait
tout pour tromper le consommateur en
imitant les pharmacies officiel en ligne
ces plateformes sont hébergés par
différents fournisseurs d'accès répartis
partout dans le monde
donc pour nous ça veut dire qu'il faut
enquêter dans cinq six ou sept endroits
différents parfois jusqu aux caïmans
résultat on a peu de chances d'attraper
les gens qui se trouvent vraiment
derrière tout ça de savoir qui est à
l'initiative de ces sites en europe le
manque à gagner pour les industriels est
estimé à 10
5 milliards d'euros par an au siège de
bayer le géant pharmaceutique allemand
on prend la chose au sérieux
chaque contrefaçon repéré est
soigneusement analyser ça c'est un
original ça c'est une contrefaçon
original contrefaçon et c'est bien
limiter le coût de cambouis c'est très
bien imité pour améliorer la traçabilité
des médicaments
l'union européenne voudrait imposer aux
industriels un nouveau système de codage
plus fiable et surtout unifiée à
l'échelle communautaire
une bonne nouvelle pour ce responsable
sécurité si chaque pays d'europe met en
place sa propre solution on va avoir de
gros problèmes
notre chaîne de distribution est
vraiment organiser de manière
internationale et sans une
uniformisation au niveau européen elle
ne fonctionnerait plus du tout quelques
contrefaçon ont en effet été repéré à
l'intérieur des circuits légaux de
médicaments mais ils restent
relativement rares
alors pour les spécialistes en
contournant la question d'internet
l'union européenne ne s'attaque pas au
coeur du problème et de problème
la question ce n'est pas de savoir si on
doit vendre les produits avec ou sans
code-barres puisque de toute façon une
partie des gens sont prêts à acheter des
médicaments des sacs plastique sans
notice sans emballage et sans ordonnance
il ne se rend même pas compte qu'ils
prennent des risques pour le frij en
grande bretagne plus de six personnes
sont déjà mortes suite à une overdose de
viagra les campagnes de sensibilisation
sur le sujet reste pourtant rare d'après
une étude réalisée par les industriels
un européen sur cinq achèterait ces
médicaments sur internet avec une chance
sur deux de tomber sur de la contrefaçon
alors là pour ce reportage à francfort
notre invité dans l'europe hebdo et
françoise grossetête bonjour alors vous
êtes membre du ppe vous êtes eurodéputée
française également membre de la
commission environnement et santé
publique on me dit vous êtes de la
spécialiste on va dire des médicaments
quand vous voyez ce ce reportage la tête
qu on vient de le voir aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
l'europe fait ce qu'il faut pour le pour
lutter contre ce fléau
l'europe essaye de traiter de ce
problème c'est vrai que le parlement
européen le demandait déjà depuis un
certain nombre d'années et nous avons
été obligés de faire une pression
importante auprès de la commission
européenne pour qu'enfin une proposition
ne soit fait il ya déjà quelques temps
alors aujourd'hui nous sommes près
d'aboutir
d'abord à cheval à ce vote une directive
qui aura lieu sans doute à l'automne
prochain sous présidence belge de
l'union européenne
aboutir à un accord de première lecture
avec le conseil
mais moi en ce qui me concerne je suis
déjà déçu la dre avant peut-être avant
votre réaction qu'est ce qu'il y a en
quelques mots dans cette danse projet de
directive alors c'est d'ailleurs ce que
l'on a vu dans votre reportage c'est que
l'on va mettre en place la traçabilité
du médicament donc cette traçabilité qui
est proposée d'ailleurs un petit peu
comme celle que nous avons su imposer
dans le domaine de la sécurité
alimentaire il ya déjà un certain nombre
d'années donc cette traçabilité qui doit
pouvoir permettre de suivre le
médicament depuis le
la première étape de la fabrication
jusqu'à la production et la délivrance
aux patients donc ça s'éteint c'est un
point très positif
c'est une avancée parce qu'on voit que
les
les médicaments contrefaits viennent
d'asie où d'ailleurs les médicaments
contrefaits ils viennent effectivement
et on l'a vu dans le reportage et
viennent d'asie la plupart du temps je
crois qu'il faut pas se tromper non plus
on a trouvé dans l'union européenne
des petits laboratoires qui font aussi
de la falsification médicaments je sais
qu'il y à il ya encore deux ans on en a
trouvé un petit laboratoire dans ma
propre région que la région rhône alpes
donc il faut faire très attention
la falsification des médicaments on peut
la trouver partout c'est de la
criminalité en général alors quand il
s'agit de grands réseaux comme les
réseaux asiatiques et à cesser de la
criminalité
ce sont des vrais réseaux mafieux en
somme qui font commerce de cette
falsification des médicaments mais on
n'est jamais à l'abri de ce petit
laboratoire qui va donc c'est pas
vraiment refait très loin de chez nous
vous dites que vous êtes déçu
qu'est-ce qui vous déçoit dans cette
directive jeu j'aurais souhaité parce
qu'il s'agit d'un problème très grave
parce qu'il s'agit quand il s'agit de
falsification c'est à dire de
contrefaçon il ne s'agit pas de
contrefaçon de n'importe quel produit de
consommation
il s'agit de médicaments c'est à dire
des produits qui ont trait à la santé
publique et qui peuvent être de ce fait
particulièrement dangereux on a eu des
cas de mortalité et dans les cales et
les mois les moins graves
vous avez un patient qui prend un
médicament qui est persuadé qu'il se
soigne et ce médicament
ne fait rien c'est de la poudre
inoffensive et dans d'autres cas on peut
avoir à faire à des mélanges qui sont
particulièrement nocifs
donc puisqu'on touche à la santé
publique il faut vraiment faire le
maximum pour être ambitieux mais je
trouve que cette proposition là n'est
pas suffisamment ambitieuse il aurait
fallu pour aller plus loin qu est ce qu
il fallait alors je vous donne un
exemple on va on autorise dans cette ce
projet directive on autorise ce qu'on
enlevait un appel le reconditionnement
c'est là que vous avez une boîte de
médicaments initial et cette boîte de
médicaments qui étaient destinés à être
vendus dans l'ain px1 états membres x
delà de l'union européenne va être
rachetée par des importateurs parallèle
par exemple être achetés pour être
vendus dans un autre état membre de
l'union européenne et pour cela on
comprend très bien
il faut à ce moment là qu'on change la
boîte de médicaments parce qu'il faut
qu'elles soient rédigés dans la langue
de l état membre dans le calice cela se
produit sera vendu et il faut que la
notice aussi soient rédigés dans la
langue alors de ce fait on accepte le
reconditionnement de cette boîte et le
fait que l'on puisse ouvrir en somme une
boîte de médicaments que l'on puisse
extraire la plaquette de pilules vers la
traçabilité
on perd la traçabilité alors on va me
répondre oui mais on aura on va avoir un
code-barres et cetera mais moi je dis
chaque fois que l'on peut toucher à la
boîte initiale du médicament on a une
porte d'entrée de la falsification
bien évidemment ne me faites pas dire ce
que je ne veux pas dire les importateurs
parallèles sont la plupart du temps des
sociétés très très sérieuse et qui sont
rigoureuses mais 1 1
falsificateur peut très bien justement
profiter de cette opportunité là on va
écouter une question d'une personne
qu'on a vu dans le reportage et qui
souhaitent justement vous poser une
question précise à écouter voilà ma
question aux hommes politiques européens
comment faire pour mettre fin au
commerce illégal sur internet
pourquoi ne pas discuter directement
avec nos amis américains qui ont une
responsabilité dans la prolifération de
ces sites internet illégaux
si l'on veut lutter contre la
contrefaçon
il faut lutter au niveau international
je pense que cela doit être notre
priorité c'est bien plus urgent que de
renforcer la traçabilité du système
légal
alors aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya 80%
des médicaments contrefaits qui sont
vendus sur internet parce que l'europe
n'est pas en train de se tromper de
combat
non je pense que c'est complémentaire en
réalité la traçabilité pour moi elle est
essentielle mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
absolument travailler sur le e-commerce
etc il ya un chapitre 1 qui a été
rajouté pas par le rapporteur sur cette
directive
justement pour demander saisir la
commission européenne de ce problème là
on a une vraie difficulté
alors c'est vrai qu'il faut il faut
harmoniser tout cela au niveau
international mais commençons déjà c'est
par exemple possible de vendre des
médicaments sur internet sa cible en
france oui bien sûr et c'est possible
dans d'autres pays que l'allemagne aussi
c'est pour cela qu'il faut absolument
arriver à faire une proposition
de réglementation et de contrôle de la
vente par internet pour qu'on ait des
sites par exemple qui seraient des sites
homologués par l'union européenne et
dans lesquels les patients pourraient
avoir toute confiance
c'est là que nous faisons pour l'instant
n'a pas réglé le problème il ya un
chapitre qui propose cela nous attendons
bien sûr la réponse de la commission
européenne et du conseil sur cette
affaire mais c'est essentiel très bien
merci beaucoup
françoise grossetête d'avoir fait avec
nous le le point sur ce dossier de la
contrefaçon des médicaments
on va maintenant parler de la bande
dessinée est un festival européen de la
bande dessinée qui se tient à strasbourg
et c'est jusqu'au 6 juin regarder
1949 quelque part en europe centrale un
orphelinat
accueil des enfants qui ont survécu à un
étrange virus un virus qui transforme
les amants monstre
sarah disant nouvelle pensionnaire va
révéler les secrets des vieux murs de ce
manoir
voilà si vous aimez les bulles et bien
rendez vous à strasbourg jusqu'au 6 juin
prochain et si la fin d'europe hebdo on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine sur les
chaînes parlementaires